the difference is how you handle your  jealousy everybody's jealous how you  express your jealousy that's what  matters i'm jealous over her like but  the way she expresses hers  the way she expresses her that's what  makes the difference but it's different  when there's a million women in his  inbox you know being like oh if you need  a green card come marry me the tidy  whitey scene talk about my man's junk  okay  so many dms about it i'm like all right  well  we all the time so all these women can  back off  kobe what are what is this about the  tidy whities ask him what's on his  underwear right now can you show us  what's on your head  [Applause]  all right  [Laughter]  that's my baby your territory is marked  yeah exactly taken you got to step it up  man exactly we got to step it up  [Music]  you